stormy webster was a princess for a day
on tuesday stormy's parents kylie jenner
and travis scott
took their three-year-old daughter to
the happiest place on earth
where else disneyland disneyland
is the best place on earth happiest
place literally
happiest place on earth the beauty mogul
shared these images to her instagram
story
showing off their special day at the
park which recently reopened its doors
again after being closed for more than a
year during the pandemic
so let's go make those magical memories
that last a lifetime
kylie captioned this photo of their
group's parade of strollers
hands full today travis shared these
pics of himself with stormy and he wrote
a forever ride stormy might be a little
young for space mountain
but it looks like she rode plenty of
disney's classic
attractions like the carousel
alice in wonderland and of course
the teacups the pixie dust filled day
follows kylie's recent comments about
stormy's future
hinting that one day her daughter could
get the keys to another magical kingdom
kylie cosmetics in the may special
edition of tomorrow magazine
the 23 year old reality star says she
hopes stormy enters the family business
if that's what she wants kylie said
quote
stormy is my legacy i'm raising her to
be smart
and kind and driven maybe she will take
over kylie cosmetics one day
only if she wants to she added becoming
a mom was the biggest change for me
i've grown so much as a person and i
continue to grow every single day
i love learning and i'm trying to be the
best person i can possibly be
when courtney was a little girl we used
to always go to disneyland oh my gosh
what is this
oh mg that is so
cute and stormy's wonderful day at
disneyland carries on a family tradition
[Music]
we've seen stormy's cousins many times
at the park over the years
maybe thanks to her aunt courtney
herself a disneyland
super fan princess makeovers and full
effect princess
jasmine princess elsa queen elsa
and cinderella in 2016 kim shared this
hilarious moment to her snapchat
showing courtney's son mason disick
channeling disney character
sleepy on the carousel i think we're
having more fun than they are
kidding i spy
mason sleeping on the carousel
he wants action
[Music]